the jurogan experience the thing is
there is
if you look at the details
a fundamental difference between what
vladimir putin is doing and what the
united states is doing now
everybody is a victim of somebody's
propaganda now i talk to russians which
is a very interesting thing
both russians and ukrainians say that
they are not at all under the influence
of propaganda russians believe there's
no propaganda in russia
and ukrainians believe there's no
propaganda in ukraine
that
from russians think the west is
influenced by their propaganda but they
see an end and the foxes and ukraine is
influenced by their propaganda by the
limited number of news channels they
have that are state controlled okay
from our western perspective that seems
ridiculous because it's obvious that
russia isn't
under influence of propaganda
so it's hard to know what is true or not
but the reality seems to be
that russia is currently an
authoritarian regime that
tries to appear as much as possible as a
democracy because there is an election
yeah and there's an extra
hard truth on top of that
i don't know what to do with it but
putin is
still
and even more so popular in russia he's
very popular
in india
in china and in russia and some small
countries around former soviet union
what do you do with that that's real
objective
well as far as we can tell data from
outside of taken from outside of the
polls taken from outside of russia
do you give any credence to the
rumors that he has cancer
i
i i'm not an investigative you know
because there's a lot of sort of rumors
of this nature oliver's don't even
discussed it he said yeah it was the
case while he was there yes he said it
very nonchalantly and i thought that was
a known fact and then later i looked and
it was
you know
i'm not sure that was objectively
publicly known but if oliver said it
then perhaps there's some
truth to it he stayed there for quite a
while when he was interviewing putin
yeah two years no he visited multiple
times and he
you spend time with them
yeah but uh according to oliver hew uh
he beat it he beat the cancer but you
know he's 69 years old seven it's going
to be 70. beating the cancer when oliver
was there versus what he has now oh what
he is now yeah because he looks like
puffy
you know which is oftentimes uh
you know
i i had we were talked about this with
the christus definite podcast
um i had a friend who had gout and they
they gave him prednisone
now he had something else too
um sarcoidosis
and they gave him prednisone and his
like
his face got big yeah and it's just like
he looked puffy
and he said it's just a side effect of
the steroids
yeah his face is puffy you know
yeah oliver stone says vladimir putin
has struggled with cancer during his
time in which the filmmaker focused on
his work on the russian president
pictured about putin waves during the
victory day parade red square may 9th
yeah well i'm much more i'm much less
concerned about the puffiness of his
face and more concerned about what's
going on with his mind it seems like
he's a different man
now than he was even a year ago
in what way
um so from this is what oliver stone
commented on and i agree
he's formed a much stricter information
bubble around him
that there is uh that isolation that a
lot of us have experienced to coven i
honestly think it might have to do with
just the isolation due to kovid you know
the basic distance you have to keep and
all that kind of stuff as a as a
political leader you have to have extra
precautions especially a political
leader that assassinates his enemies
yes
[Laughter]
well
yeah that's that too that's well no but
that
has that that was always the case that
has less to do with covet but don't you
think that increases his paranoia
yes
paranoia yeah the paranoia is the thing
that's what gets dictators
that's what gets you start mistrusting
everybody not just on the outside of the
circle but the inner circle and so you
don't know who to trust even though the
closest advisor is you don't know who to
trust so your flow of information is
really flawed yeah it's very limited
yeah and so you start
you start making really poor decisions
uh even more so than before and there
that that's where i mean if you and i
hate thinking of it that way because to
me uh the war in ukraine is a
humanitarian
[Music]
thing
not a geopolitics thing but if you think
geopolitically
invading ukraine was just a giant
miscalculation on putin's part on every
level geopolitical social militarily
unless there's
there's very few scenarios in which
this was calculated all along the only
scenarios of putin thought
through um
first of all maybe he thought that
zelensky would just back down
would just crumble under the pressure of
even a minor invasion and obviously you
have to give credit
this is really important so
ukraine
got its independence for the first time
in many centuries in 1991 30 years ago
when the soviet union collapsed so
they're dealing with independence with
sovereignty which is a difficult process
as the united states knows we had a
civil war about it and the same same
thing in ukraine there's there's
factions there's a lot of corruption
it's the second most corrupt country in
europe
next next do you see when the new york
times was questioning candace owen and
where is she getting her information
that because the new york times was
trying to push this
while the ukraine invasion was happening
they were trying to push this thing that
ukraine was good and russia is bad and
she was saying well this is one of the
most corrupt countries on earth so they
said to her like where are you getting
this information they sent her an email
and she sent them back links to the new
york times and all these articles about
how badly corrupt ukraine was which just
makes me go god damn if i can't trust a
[ __ ] new york times to get it right
like you're supposed to be the the paper
of note
but a lot has changed though
so zielinski the president he got into
office with 70 approval and before the
war he had less than 30 approval there's
factions there's divisions the west side
of ukraine is pro
let's say ukrainian and then the right
side is pro russia so he got into office
and he had a high approval rating and
then before the war it dropped very low
yeah it had been dropping gradually over
because of the division because of the
factions he wasn't able to bring the
country together
and the war
turns out
his great leadership
was catalyzed was made possible like he
was
uh sometimes sort of a catastrophe
brings out the best in us and that was
the case with him w george w bush yeah
yeah well that's exactly what happened
post 9 11. yes
the the yeah exactly but
in his case he wasn't able to hold that
for a long time let's see what zelonski
does but at the moment
he was zelonski united
a previously divided country which is
very difficult to do so that
that um
i mean that's a historic event in in in
in um
for ukraine in its sovereign
history and so in terms of corruption
that might be a really big blow to
corruption that kind of unification so
um
i think there's a fundamental difference
between the corruption in ukraine and
the corruption in russia what is the
conflict in ukraine the
beside russia what is the internal
conflict like the the factions what it
would what do they want
what is uh
what the dispute
well no there there's it's it's just
factions that are uh vying for power
that's just at the basic level so it's
basically like right versus left in
america yeah but okay so there's a bunch
of differences um what they stand for
what they're looking for a lot of it in
the recent years has been centered
around
the war
uh with russia starting with 2014.
and so
some parts are ukrainian speaking
pro-ukraine some parts are
russian-speaking or primarily
russian-speaking and pro-russia so on
the east you have the donbass region but
around that as well they
want to
be closer to russia
and the the west part wants to be closer
to europe closer to nato closer to the
european union is that that's one of the
divisions you want to be
pro-democracy or you want to be pro
whatever the heck
russia is so it's like are you pulling
towards the west to towards the west the
western civilization are you pulling
towards the east
um the way of russia the way of china
the way of those superpowers i'm sure
they're influenced and they got have
the ones who are pro-russia they're
they're getting some signals from putin
or
meeting with them and he's giving them
indications that
they would
best be served to be aligned with him
and be better for them and
yeah but he is still popular he is
there's a
i mean i don't know exactly why he's
popular but there's a longing
as it there isn't a lot of nations to be
the greatest nation on earth isn't there
always just a longing for a strong man
like the strong man leader
i would say a strong vision and that
sometimes can
coincide or often does with a strong
man
like isn't it like a natural inclination
that people have to be led by a strong
man like putin like like him or hate him
think he's evil that's all good but
there's no
doubt that he's strong he's a strong
leader he's been running russia for a
long time and the way he's been doing
that
sort of unopposed
in a ruthless manner
it's very impressive
it's evil
but in terms of its efficacy it's
impressive what he's been able to do
i think strength is one of the things we
admire in leaders but yeah the entirety
of it like
so that's why zolensky is extremely
popular he stepped up
you know the the famous thing he was uh
biden offered him a ride and he said
[ __ ] that
i'm staying put
give me more bullets
and uh he stayed in kiev kiev
and
held
held his ground where most leaders would
have fled
uh this is the failure we had in
afghanistan where we fled
here's a leader that stepped up and held
his ground and that's rare in this world
and we admire that kind of strength yes
and the same could be said by the
russian people
the indian people the chinese people
that admire strength and putin
but
we also admire
other values that make this country
great the united states of america is
this kind of
respect for human freedom human rights
and
um i mean sort of the embodiment of this
ideal of like all men are created equal
that's not exactly communicated very
clearly by vladimir putin right
um you know that's
you know
but and there's also a difference
between and this again the oliver stone
perspective is uh between the messaging
and the actual execution
you know
hitler's messaging was also
very sort of
uh
beautiful sounding right what is he
talking about sort of uh
national socialism respect for workers
right like the downtrodden workers uh
that were
germany is a great nation
that deserves to be respected among
other nations and it was not respected
because of world war one
okay but
like are you also going to mention that
you're going to murder and imprison and
torture people
millions of people you're not you're not
in the same things with america
not moral equivalence at all obviously
but we talk a lot about freedom but what
does freedom actually look like
you know when we fight terrorism and
evil in the world what does that
actually look like
well it turns out that it looks like
you're bombing
civilians children
lose their fathers and mothers
uh
hundreds of thousands of people
civilians die
when you're spreading freedom all over
the world so we have to be very careful
sort of
separating the
the messaging from the actions and we
have to as americans make sure we live
up to the ideal and we don't always
and that i think when you just paint the
whole world as black and white
it's easy for us to say america good
china russia bad yeah and instead of the
the full complexity of that and that
there's warmongers
like that watch ukraine now
with the money that we're sending there
and they get excited because it can
escalate and if they escalate they can
get more and more money for
manufacturing weapons
to both sides to all sides and what if
china enters with taiwan
that tension that military conflict
and there's nukes on the ready
everywhere